Hallo Herr.  Pratt
Hallo Mrs.  liebe mein Name ist Lulu und ich
habe eine Frage mr.  Haslem, du bist ein sehr
beliebter Mann hier in Deutschland, die Leute
mögen dich, die Leute lieben deine Filme und
Musik, also warum machst du es nicht wie Arnold
Schwarzenegger, ein mutiger Mann aus Österreich,
wir gingen in die Vereinigten Staaten und wurden
Gouverneur, warum nicht?  Wenn Sie nicht hierher nach
Deutschland kommen, einige ernsthafte Entscheidungen treffen und
vielleicht Eigentümer werden, Bundeskanzler oder sogar
Staatssekretär, könnten wir hier bald einen neuen treffen,
gehen Sie einfach.
Ich denke, das ist eine sehr gute Idee
die hoffa später und
das wird der burgermeister ich werde
der motivationsminister sein weil du
mich motiviert hast jetzt muss ich
ganz deutschland
dich motivieren